all right with that we're about three
minutes past seven so i think i'm gonna
get started
um thank you everyone for coming i'm
shannon rose mcauliffe and i'm the
manager of the student arts programs
here at mit
we're very pleased to hear from this
really fantastic panel of students and
faculty
involved in the arts at mit joining us
we have justin park from syncopation
ryan kim and john hee lee from the
logarithms and
mta professor ian hatwick thank you all
for being here um
tonight this group is going to share
with us a bit about their experiences
with playing and
recording virtual music during the
pandemic and then we'll have some time
for questions and comments
uh and before we get underway quick
disclaimer that this event is being
recorded and may be made publicly
available on the arts on the radar
website
or elsewhere in the future if you do not
wish to appear in the recording
please make sure that your video and
audio are muted during the event
and please contact us at arts on the
radar at mit.edu if you've got any
questions or concerns
and with that i'm going to turn it over
to the logarithms
hello my name is jun hee i'm the
president of the mit logs
uh we're an acapella group on campus uh
we have been around for 70 years this is
our 71st
or 72nd year performing i think so we're
a pretty old group and
by nature of acapella primarily what we
do is
sing uh so in a normal year that would
mean that we spend around
six hours a week uh separated into three
two hour rehearsals
uh rehearsing music so that
of course uh in general requires a lot
of physical
uh connection like we're all in the same
studio
singing to each other reactively uh
adjusting like volume pitch so on and so
forth
uh and uh as you can expect a lot of
music making in general is
is very collaborative and in person so
um when the
uh when we were sent home last semester
it was a
there was a big transition period uh
during which we are figuring out how we
would proceed
with the rest of the semester uh
fortunately for us we had a lot of time
to think
uh but also we had a lot of stuff kind
of taken care of beforehand
so uh we were in a situation where we
had a lot of arrangements
uh kind of figured out we are in a
situation where uh
everything that we had planned for the
semester was pretty much already done
and it was just a matter of
uh of finding a way to perform it
somehow
so that made the transition process much
easier but
ultimately what we ended up doing uh we
had a
weekly zoom meeting um during which most
of the time we actually didn't rehearse
most of the time it was actually just
social but simultaneously there was a
lot of time spent
going over old arrangements sometimes
new arrangements
uh annotating and thinking about what we
want it to sound like what we how we
should sing our parts um
and also listening to the music we were
supposed to be learning uh so
kind of the individual processes that we
would normally do to prepare for a
rehearsal uh we just kind of did it
together in zoom
and that was kind of how we replaced
in-person uh like auditory rehearsals
and then simultaneously we had a lot of
music prepared that we wanted to share
so uh we really really wanted to find a
way to present that
so uh our primary inspiration was
through a bunch of other musicians
who've already been doing this even
without the pandemic
like for instance like eric whittaker
had a concert
a virtual choir concert that was very
very popular had a lot of singers and
also like
artists like jacob collier have done
lots and lots of collaborative videos
with merge videos and audio and so we
thought it would be a good idea to
produce videos that
were produced separately recorded audio
and video
in remote distant locations and then
combined and produced into one final
product
and then we also had an idea to uh to
cue our videos stockpile them and then
release them all in kind of a concert
style at the end of the semester
so that was the framework for how our
semester went down um
overall we had a pretty productive
semester uh
the amount of music learning that we did
and the amount of
music making that we did was actually
not very different from what we would
normally do
uh in a semester so uh well
i think that what we did was a pretty
good replacement at least for our
uh our way of functioning and also the
um twitch stream at the end of the
semester was also surprisingly more
successful than we thought it would be
um and it was a lot of fun to get to
kind of watch
that come together and see the audience
enjoying it
although there's of course no again no
uh
auditory or in-person reaction but it
was cool to see
that there are a lot of people watching
giving comments and stuff like that
um as for the more technical aspects
of what we did over the semester i'm
going to hand that over to
ryan um brian was our ryan is our event
coordinator and he was in charge
of most of the concert that we put in
that we produced at the end of
last semester so um yeah i'll turn it
over to ryan and you can talk more about
that
yeah thanks juni um great to be here
with you all
so we um as juni said we did some remote
remote acapella productions this past
semester
um because we weren't able to be
physically on campus together we found a
way to remotely record different tracks
and combine them
into kind of a cohesive acapella product
um which included both
audio and video and one of the things um
i think is really cool about our
production is that it was entirely
self-contained
we didn't hire anyone to do any audio
editing or video editing for us and
a lot of us didn't know that much about
this beforehand but we um
we were able to learn throughout the pro
the pandemic
and eventually create something that
we're pretty proud of at the end
so i guess first of all um how this
actually ended up going down is
we start with an arrangement which is
the center of an acapella
um an acapella production and an
arrangement is basically where we
um an arrangement is basically where
someone
writes down all the notes that everyone
is going to sing
um including vocal percussion beatboxing
um and just all the different rhythms
all the different syllables that people
are gonna sing
um the solo all the harmonies and we
have that all down on a couple sheets of
paper
um and we we send that out to everyone
normally
and what we do in in this remote time is
we
transformed that um paper sheet into a
digital file and then we sent that out
to everyone so a digital audio file
um which contained basically how we
envisioned the song
um being sung and then everyone listened
to that recording
and then um recorded themselves singing
their part
so looking at the sheet music and
listening to the reference track they
would record their part
um and all and everyone would upload it
to a central google drive file
then the person who's mixing the audio
so mixing is a term
um just an audio production meaning just
to combine all the different
audio tracks and do um
and yeah make sure all the volume levels
are right do different
apply different effects do things like
modify the frequencies um to make to
make the sounds a little bit different
and i guess i'll show a little bit about
what that mixing process looks like i'm
going to share my screen right now
but basically if you look here um here
is one of our projects i think this is
actually our most involved project
but we have um so
everyone filmed two tracks a left track
and a right track
um because that creates a greater sense
of space for the
for the listener and then we would
combine all these tracks together in the
different voice parts
um and then we did some timing issues
because
um in person it's easy to get a sense of
where everyone is like sometimes
if someone rushes at one part um the
whole group is able to kind of
compensate for that but because we're
recording remotely
it's harder um to to anticipate how
others are going to sing
and sometimes there's need for timing
correction or also pitch correction
but we did all of that within this file
and then
um we also recorded some extra parts
like for example
there's a clapping section um towards
the end of this song
and i actually just recorded myself
clapping like 10 times into my mic
microphone right here um so you can see
on the screen right here just a bunch of
recordings of me clapping
um at slightly different times and it
creates the illusion that there's a
chorus
on clapping but yeah we were able to
combine all these all these different
tracks and
apply certain effects
some examples of effects are reverb
which
creates um creates a sense that you're
in a larger like a concert hall or
something because there's
different copies of the sound coming at
later times or different reverberations
um there's an effect called called eq
which is um where you modify the
different frequencies that are
um within a sound file and you can
emphasize certain parts of the sound
um to create a really different feel um
and yeah that was that was about it for
the recording and then we had everyone
also record videos alongside
um and we combined those videos together
and i think
i'm going to screen share real quick
what that ended up looking like
so is is the audio playing
[Music]
okay
[Music]
ain't it fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you
[Music]
so yeah um that was what our final
product ended up looking like
we had um we ended up having
i think seven seven six or seven songs
um that we created for the semester and
we
streamed it on twitch and it ended up
being pretty successful we were pretty
happy with how it turned out
so i think that's about all i have um
thank you for having us
and i'll turn it over to the next group
perfect
thank you so much that was really
exciting and next i'm going to invite
justin from syncopation to get up on the
figurative stage let's go
hello everyone thank you for having me
so yeah
as have been introduced so my name is
justin i'm a third year undergraduate at
mit
and i'm here on behalf of the acapella
group syncopation
so uh we're of course in a very
but we're in a very similar situation to
the logs into
all the other acapella groups on campus
in that
this past semester we've been unable to
perform a concert live
and so you're struggling with what
should we do
in terms of producing music over the
semester and also
over this the following summer so we
decided to take a similar approach and
we considered putting together some
recording projects
and so we had a number of arrangements
which we were
considering one of the biggest problems
as has been touched on by
junior and by ryan is the difficulty of
rehearsing in a super efficient way
while virtual so we
decided to focus our efforts mostly on
the
recording aspect of it and so we picked
we looked at the list of songs that we
have
already performed and haven't gotten
around to recording yet
or ones that we've been working on but
haven't been able to fully bring to life
because
we all got booted off campus and such
so yeah so we decided to take that
approach we recorded
um all our audio and video virtually
and pieced that together from home
had a number of people working on that
so
just to share some details of how that
how that worked i personally was
on the production committee so to speak
for
cinco this semester this past semester
and i
in particular handled the audio editing
for
for our projects that we put together so
what that entailed is a lot of the same
what ryan
showed earlier so it involved the mixing
it involved involved
retrieving everyone's audio files
balancing them properly doing
pitch and timing corrections
perhaps one of the
quick learnings i had from that is
one is that i have a newfound respect
for people who do it professionally
uh having to do that all myself
realizing that there's a lot
that can go in to make something really
sound good and really
uh like come through as a powerful mix
that you might hear in a
professional recording um but it was
also a really cool experience
because i had almost no knowledge about
this going in
and so just learning how to do this from
scratch
fiddling around with the software
fiddling around with things i could find
on google
you know if anything is a testament to
just diving in and trying it
uh tossing tossing things together to
mix it
key takeaway i think for me is that
there's a lot more than just
tossing everything together and trying
to line everything up so it sounds good
ryan showed earlier a lot of the work
that goes into
balancing things and making sure that
patient timings all match up
there's also a lot you can do just with
with individual tracks a number
a number of softwares even something
free like audacity you can do things
such as
noise removals you can compress your
audio tracks
you can change the eq so you can make
certain tracks open up a little more
make them sound a little less muffled
boost the bass if you're on track that
requires a bit more of that
whether it's a vocal bass or vocal
percussion
and so just getting a sense of how that
works balancing
those properly so that every track
really comes through the way you want it
to
in the final mix i think is
something that there's no fixed handbook
to
and it's something that you really get
just by fiddling around with it
i think is the biggest takeaway
to develop just
trial and error to figure out what works
the best
yeah um i don't want to dive too much
into the technical
details of how i did the audio mixing uh
on the video end
we actually had a lot of fun with this
video uh for
one this one project in particular
because let me share my screen
experience everyone yeah
so we had a lot of fun with this
this one particular project so this is
something that we had performed
last fall and so we performed it at
concert and we were planning on
recording the song
in studio for to get it professionally
mixed and such but we didn't
get around to doing that because because
we all had to leave campus
and so we considered well this is a nice
hype song um
anyone who's familiar with k-pop is
likely to know this song because
syncopation being the
east asian interest a cappella group on
campus
one of the big genres we sing is is this
sort of kpop
and so we thought okay you know this
song by bts it's a nice hype song
so we decided to record it but we
thought how could we kind of make this
give it our own little twist and
there we saw all sorts of acapella
covers going around and
making the rounds on facebook uh with
different groups
all over the country around the world
and a zoom themed cover seemed to be
fairly common so we really decided to
kind of hone in on that idea
just like people from the logs mentioned
earlier
everyone just recorded their themselves
singing along
within their video and sent it to sent
it over for
our video editor daniel lou for this
project
and we kind of went with the zoom theme
so
we added a lot of these little corks
across the board
you know kind of this little chat
feature the zoom tiles
[Music]
insider secret the reason we had the
videos flicker on one by one at the
start
is because some people's videos started
later than we would have liked so
you know hide the arrow with the
staggered entrance
looks cool though and it looks very
zoomy yeah
make with it what you can i suppose yeah
so
we had we had a lot of fun with this
project because there were a lot of
things that we could do
with regards to giving the these little
quirks that people who use zoom are very
familiar with
uh for example if i can like escape
forward a bit
uh right up the course
apologies my internet's not fantastic
i want something stronger
all right it looks like we're having a
bit of an internet connection difficulty
with justin are you back
yep i'm back i'm sorry my internet's uh
potentially a little
questionable right now please don't
worry we've got about two more minutes
so if you want to wrap it up
that would be great that was a really
excellent video yeah sure so
yeah um one thing i didn't quite get the
show off there which i won't make an
attempt right now just because
my internet might die again we did a
little things where we
added some quirks we there's a second
solos so when they switched over we did
like uh
they raised their hand over zoom to
start soloing
we added a little zoom emojis when the
vocal percussion did fancy things
and so this was really nice because it
was also really cool collaborative
effort
something that even though one person
was spearheading the video editing
it was something a lot of people could
give feedback on in designing the
storyboard so to speak for the whole
video
uh deciding what little features we
could add in where transition should
happen
and so this this is a really cool way
for us to
still be able to work collaboratively on
a project
it wasn't just people recording
sending it to two people to do all the
work even past that people could still
contribute their ideas
find ways to give their feedback on
the way the audio is coming along on how
we what we could do for the video
we had a number of iterations of both
the audio
where we sent it to the group and made
sure everyone was
really on the same page with where this
project was going
and so yeah i think uh overall i'd say
that
doing this sort of recording project we
put together we put together
uh some other recordings as well over
the
semester in the summer this is i think
the biggest one we did the one i just
showed you
but these sorts of projects i think were
really cool way to stay connected
over the semester and over the summer uh
to keep
producing news together to really feel
like everyone's
getting involved in this and really
still
contributing uh to the group and to what
we
like to do you know just make music for
the community
so yeah it's been an awesome experience
and we're definitely gonna
continue recording and producing things
this semester
excellent thank you so much if you want
you we would love for you to share some
of the uh
other recording projects that you've
done um probably in the chat would be
the best but we can also take those via
email and send them out to people as
well
all right and with that we are going to
go to our last presentation
and that is professor ian hatwick take
it away
all right so um so i'm ian atwork i'm a
professor
at mit in the music technology
department in music and theater arts
and i'm also the director of family
which is the mit laptop ensemble
so i thought i'd talk a little bit about
how family has approached
performing and rehearsing remotely and
uh
sort of how last semester when and what
we're doing this semester and it's
pretty different it was really great to
hear the earlier two presentations
um obviously the acapella community at
mit is really strong and they've done
lots of things
over the years and i've actually in my
classes had quite a few acapella
students
learn about reporting so i was actually
i was curious to see
how sort of the existing knowledge
within the acapella community would feed
into
the ability to deal with with this
transition and these during these remote
recordings which
uh we're both really super successful so
good congratulations and good job on
that
um but what we what we ended up doing is
really different and actually we were
the only
ensemble at mit that i know of that
kept our performance schedule exactly
the same as it was uh before
the transition to being remote um as it
was um after
so we were able to do that because the
laptop ensemble
already focuses on network music
performance and i guess with that i
should maybe sort of like
mention a little bit about what the
laptop is all about like what a laptop
ensemble is
so we're uh ensemble a small group uh
generally around
six to seven to eight people who perform
together using
laptops as our primary sound source and
interface um sometimes we'll use midi
controllers or other kind of like
hardware
uh but most of the time all of the sound
that we're gener we're working with is
generated in a laptop and then
um either send out and play through a
speaker or uh when we're playing
remotely
uh we would um send it out over zoom or
something like that
over youtube streaming for concerts so a
lot of the focus on this is what does a
laptop
bring to an ensemble context and how do
we perform electronic music together and
it's not at all
obvious for a lot of people how that
would work play out
electronic music the way that we see it
most of the time is actually
a solo or a duo at the most working
together we see djs we see solo artists
and this idea of having an ensemble of
people communicating
is not that common nowadays and the neat
thing about it is it
gives new ways of collaborating that uh
that really are still were in their in
the early days of exploring how this can
work
um so before even their their switch to
being remote happened we were already
doing network music we were
experimenting
with uh creating information on my
laptop and sending that information to
your laptop and you can take that
information
and use it to generate music and then
you can send your information to
somebody else's laptop and they can use
that information to generate music
and then you're hearing all of that at
the same time so i thought maybe i'd
play a couple of videos just to orient
you
about uh what our normal performance
practice is like
and then play a couple of videos also of
what happened last semester and i can
talk about
how that played out and and how we set
up the system to be able to do that
so that being said
so this is a recap
of of course the zooman is blocking me
of our 29th fall in 2019 season
so
[Music]
so one of the things that you're not
seeing in this right now is that every
performer has their own speaker that's
right next to them so the idea is that
it's just like it would be in a music
ensemble when somebody's making sound
that sound is coming from that
performer's location
and when you're in the room with
everyone the sound is distributed
according to the ensemble so you can
tell what everybody is doing and there's
really a sense of spatial
identity and spatial resonance in the
room
and we were to do all different kinds of
uh formations we would
stand in small circles we would sit down
on the floor by the piano
uh we would sit amongst the audience
sometimes we would go and sit
and stand all the way around the room in
a giant circle
and uh and even like walk around a
little bit
so really would play around with space a
lot play around with spatialization a
lot
really concerned with this idea of
sharing musical materials things like
that
so when it came time to move remotely
uh we were able to take that same
approach and move it online
and one of the reasons why we were able
to do that so successfully is that we're
already sharing information over
networks
right that's part of our normal practice
so the idea that we're sharing
information over the internet remotely
across you know
across the us and in taiwan it was
really easy for us to do that but we did
have to create some new software
that would generate all of the sound
that you would hear um
everybody's laptop would basically
generate all of the sounds so everybody
would be hearing the sound
from everybody's sound on their laptop
and then everybody's sending control
messages to everybody else's giant
network
of people sending information back and
forth um
one of the interesting things about last
semester too that was slightly different
is that we were using
a controller so this piece uh cursors
is using a launchpad grid controller as
our input device
and uh we had a visual visualization for
this piece
where everybody had control over one
little chunk of this circular sequence
and they could control the notes and
placements on the sequence
and interact both with placing events
and also interact with this cursor which
is triggering events
this is a little bit of this piece
cursors
[Music]
so
[Music]
so uh when we performed this this
is actually a video that i produced uh
for uh
mta event but this is also exactly how
we would perform it all of these videos
of this performances were taking place
at the same time
so this was a real-time performance uh
in all these different locations we just
had everybody sort of use a webcam to
record their local video
and then we edited it together to a nice
presentation but we would do the same
thing
for concerts so this is a concert
that we did over zoom
and we actually the way we did it is we
would had a big zoom room where
everybody was in and then we were
streaming
the audio and the video from my laptop
through youtube studio and actually we
would stream different people's
um uh people different people would
share their screens
and restream from one laptop to youtube
uh
streaming services and so this is
another concert that we did another live
concert that was played synchronously
[Music]
and i think we're getting basically a
mono sound here zoom it does not play
very well with stereo sound
but one component that you're missing is
we're also able to implement
a 360 degree spatial audio algorithm
so you could actually hear each person's
sound coming from a different location
in space you're not getting that right
now
because uh zoom does not support uh
stereo audio uh natively
um anyways
so that was something that we were able
to do like i said largely because we
were already working with
uh network performances um and
uh enabled us to translate that into in
sort of this virtual
um this virtual setting so this semester
and the reason one reason why i wanted
to show that last video is this semester
we're
doing entirely online some of the other
semesters at mit or i'm sorry some of
the other ensembles at mit
are trying to bring in some synchronous
even some in-person rehearsal and
performance and
i decided that since working virtually
works really well for us it's actually
pretty comfortable
based on the way that we work we would
stay entirely virtual so everybody has
the same experience there's no
concern about whether people are on
campus or not and
we're also exploring something else
which is a live coding performance
so live coding is this situation where
people are typing code in real time
executing it
and then it generates sound so just to
give you a quick sense of what live
coding looks like
this is our live coding environment
we're using
where we're actually writing code and
then executing it
to uh generate sound i'm not getting
sound right now
just because it's not playing nicely
brazil
but um but that's what we're going to be
doing this semester so again like a
really different perspective than
syncopation
and the logarithms and a lot of the
other ensembles at mit because the
system is very natural for us
so maybe i'll wrap up right there i do
have a lot of questions
for the other two presenters in the mit
community generally there's
a lot of really interesting ways of
approaching dealing with this virtual
music performance but i'll wrap up my
section and we can move on to a q a
or have a look at this just basically
handled my transition for me i was about
to thank all of you
and suggest that we move into some q a
if anybody has any questions please feel
free to pop them in the chat or to use
the raise hand function
and i guess i will start about how
you're all planning to i mean
ian touched on this but how is everybody
planning to continue rehearsing
and producing music virtually i open up
the floor
for us our approach is very similar to
this last semester so we're going to
continue uh producing videos and
trying to hold another concert at the
end of the semester i think the main
difference
uh this semester will be that what we're
actually trying to rehearse
uh so of course there's still not going
to be
any uh audio syncing through zoom uh
and they're going to be latency delays
but what we're trying to do is just uh
share computer sound sing along to
ourselves kind of emulate the
the concept of rehearsal uh without the
reactiveness
so um that's going to be one way we're
going to try to
uh enhance the music learning process
especially since we're doing all
all new arrangements this semester does
anyone else want to say something
i have some questions actually if
anybody has any interest or time i know
it's a big subject but
um i'm a musician myself and we've been
struggling to come up with ideas for
using low latency programs so if anybody
has any ideas about that
i'd be really curious to hear about it i
could probably try now um unless
somebody else wants to
i'll go ahead go ahead so there's a lot
of different ways that people haven't
tried to do
low latency audio there's actually a
move right now i think it's called
lamit low latency audio at mit uh
professor aaron ngozi is another
professor in the music tech department
at mta
has been organizing this um
so there's been a community of people
who would do network music for a long
time and they use this tool called jack
trip it's an open source
uh low latency audio network uh
connection where you can stream audio
from multiple locations to other
multiple locations so you can do this
kind of like multi-site
real-time performance but this really
challenging to do this in a way that's
that's effective we all know that zoom
doesn't work right
um and the reason why is because zoom
has all this latency which is built into
buffer the audio
um and so jack tripp is trying to
implement a more efficient network we
can sort of share audio in real time
but you're always going to be limited by
a couple of things you're limited first
of all by the speed of light
which is actually not inconsiderable
when you're dealing with
intercontinental audio
which can be added many milliseconds of
delay to the audio and then also
signals going through the internet the
internet is not designed for real-time
network transmission it's designed for
buffer and it's designed to get
information there
reliably rather than in time
so um so dealing with these things can
be really tricky i think that what iran
has found
well if you have a really robust
internet network like mit does like an
academic university does
you can leverage that academic network
which is going to be
not have many of the same latency
problems
that commercial internet will have like
our home internet will have much worse
latency than a university
infrastructure internet so if
everybody's at a university
then using something like draft trick to
jack trip to do lillian's audio is
actually pretty feasible
um again mostly feasible within like a
four or five hundred mile range because
once you got out of 400 500 miles the
speed of light becomes a factor in terms
of delay
um so that i think is sort of the
situation
that's going on with that if you're
trying to do lowlands audio locally
it's not impossible but also to set
these things up is not technically
trivial so you it takes a lot of trial
and error and a lot of
sort of like sitting down figuring the
stuff out so possible but not easy
most people aren't doing it if it was
easy people would be doing it all over
the place
it's hard enough that most people are
not doing it has anybody here had any
experience with that
i was actually i just wanted to tag
something on that so i haven't got an
experience yet but i will be because i'm
also part of the chamber music program
and emerson so i've like
been discussing with the people there
about
working with this low latency technology
so i've seen a lot of the
what's been discussed about it and
regarding syncopation specifically we've
considered the option of using
this low latency technology and we might
for just like the occasional
jam session or whatever but like the
logs mentioned we won't be
doing rehearsals in the traditional
sense of like singing
synchronously because even if we get
everything optimal we have people on the
other side of the planet
and at a certain point they'll lately a
late
low latency solutions just don't work um
so we're definitely limited in that
sense and so
our rehearsals this semester are
we're labeling them more as workshops
because we don't they're not going to be
rehearsals in the same
the usual sense like singing together
and doing everything synchronously
um yeah we are still planning to produce
things
similar to how we did this past semester
but
unfortunately we still won't be able to
get the same feel
of singing together
that's great to hear um i also saw that
ryan
looked like he was trying to chime in at
one point so as we're about to wrap up i
just want to make sure that he has a
chance to come in too
oh um i mean most of what i was going to
say was actually said by ian and justin
um i guess i'll add in that we did end
up trying
a low latency solution on a program
called jam kazam
um and it was um it was not feasible
with someone
um across the country like i tried doing
it with i'm
i'm based in virginia and i tried doing
it with someone in california and the
delays were like something like a tenth
of a second which is just
um a non-starter for simultaneous
rehearsal i did try it with a friend in
dc so he was about 40 miles away
and it was um it was pretty acceptable
at that point
so i think in the future especially if
the software is improved
perhaps we can't do cross-country but
something like if everyone's in boston
um but we can't meet up in person due to
um social distancing requirements
um we could all rose together in a room
i could see that becoming a reality at
some point although probably not
before the end of this man that way
all right we are coming up on the end of
the session this has been really
fantastic if anybody has any
part in shots i would love to hear them
but um
if not i'd like to invite you to stick
around um
in this room we'll have a 15-minute
break and there's going to be some slide
shows happening with some information
surrounding all of arts on the radar and
there's going to be some nifty trivia
about the arts at mit so um if you feel
like hanging out that would be great
and if you'd rather get up stretch have
a drink of water or something
at eight o'clock in this room we'll be
doing a round table panel
with some of our most actively engaged
student artists at mit and they'll
discuss
their experiences um engaging with
arts on campus and virtually and uh
in this in the other zoom room um which
we can send information about on the
website there
is um a presentation a maker workshop
through
um act arts culture and technology so
um with that i beat you all farewell
thank you all so much
thank you thank you for having us
cutting across the archive from photo
montage to digital folklore
this advanced photography course is
designed for students who wish to
explore photography
images and archives as tools and
resources for artistic practices
the course focuses on the use of
archival images and photographic
practices
while encouraging students to explore
analog digital and
new technologies through lectures
readings film screenings
student driven projects visiting artist
presentations and critic sessions
students experiment with a range of
artistic strategies while engaging in
cross-disciplinary research and working
on collaborative and individual
assignments across a diverse spectrum of
themes and historical context students
read and discuss theoretical texts
related to the use of archives and
artistic
practices
advanced video and related media this
course introduces advanced strategies of
image and sound manipulation
both technical and conceptual we'll
cover everything from pre-production
planning
storyboards and scripting through the
refinement of digital editing techniques
visual effects such as chroma keying
post-production
as well as audio and sonic components
context is provided by regular viewings
of contemporary video artworks
and other audio visual formats
video installation is a contemporary and
expanding art genre that intersects with
the world of architecture engineering
programming
new media and performance practices in
this intermediate to advanced course
students are encouraged to expand the
current themes and methods within their
art or research practices by
experimenting with various video
installation strategies
such as video mapping to 3d objects
site-specific architectural projects
multi-channel projection environments
mixing moving image content with live
performance
wearable sculptures live feeds physical
computing or
other elements of interest
you